(upbeat music)
- My name is Kelly McLemore, co-organizer
of Corgi Beach Day.
Our dog, Mr. Pickles, was on Facebook
back in October 2012, and we decided that
we wanted to meet some
Facebook dogs in person
and their owners.
So the first one that we had,
we had about 12 Corgis here
and then we decided to do another one
and 75 Corgis showed up,
then it was 250, 300, 400,
and today it's probably
close to 600 maybe.
(upbeat music)
- I didn't think it would grow this big,
but I'm definitely
thinking it's going to get
even bigger than this.
- This is her first time at the beach.
She's not digging the water,
but she loves the sand.
- I met, Winston, the white Corgi
who I do follow and that
was pretty exciting.
He keeps coming over to drink our water.
My name is Tina and I'm
the proud mom of Winston
the white Corgi right here.
There's a lot of people
who love him obviously,
but all he wants to do is play fetch.
We're just trying to have a blast
and make sure we say hi to everyone
and it's fun.
- It's kind of overwhelming for him.
He made me carry him
from the car a mile away.
- She's a puppy.
She's about four months old.
We've been here for about three hours
and she was done after an hour.
- These are my two Corgis.
They're wearing left shark
and right shark costumes.
- We are one of the original
12 Corgis that were here
in October 2012.
Today they are dressed
as Mexican (mumbling).
- This is our dog.
- Carrot.
He's just been a very athletic dog.
- Eventually he learned to
bounce the ball with his nose.
(crowd cheering)
- [Voiceover] What does the
world love about Corgis so much?
- They're great companions.
They're good looking dogs.
- They're fun, they're intelligent,
they're loving.
She cuddles.
She'll talk to you.
- They have the stumpy
legs and they run around
and fall over things easily
because they're so small
and their tongue is always hanging out,
so they're kind of entertaining
just to watch on their own.
- When they jump in the air
the bottom part just like
follows up with them, you know?
It's just like a huge wave, you know?
- The only thing about them is they shed
and I've had probably 10
different breeds of dogs
and I keep coming back to the Corgi.
- I'm Susan from Queen's
Best Stumpy Dog Rescue.
We're a rescue that specializes in Corgis
and Corgi mixes.
There are plenty of pure
bred Corgis that need homes.
To this date, we've placed
about 30 dogs in homes.
(upbeat music)
- We love Buzz Feed, bye.